salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi et
c'est donc le jour de l'astuce de la
semaine je suis un petit peu mais alors
un tout petit peu à la bourre sur le
tournage des vidéos et donc je vous ai
demandé il ya une heure de temps sur
twitter sur facebook sur instagram est
sûre snapshots que vous vouliez comme
astuce pour aujourd'hui et j'ai bien
fait de faire ça parce que vous m'avez
donné plein de réponses pour ce pack en
une heure je re temps de réponse et hop
j'en ai donc choisi une pour aujourd'hui
et j'en ai gardé une qui me servira
samedi pour le master class ce sera
master class sur les entretiens
d'embauché
tremblay recruteurs par les abonnés
seront prêts mais aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler du démarchage téléphonique
vous savez ce sont ceux qui vous appelle
pour vous vendre quelque chose que ce
soit en téléphonie en assurance ou plein
d'autres choses et vous vous retrouvez
pris au piège avec un commercial qui
sait très bien faire son boulot
alors aujourd'hui je vous donne mes six
astuces face démarchage téléphonique
il faudrait commencer par définir qui
sont les personnes qui nous démarchent
les personnes qui sont à l'autre bout du
fil ce sont des personnes comme vous et
moi ils travaillent en fait c'est leur
gagne pain
donc eux ils n'y sont pour rien à la
base ils n'ont pas décidé de vous
appelez vous tiens je vais essayer de
vendre une assurance au fabien olicard
aujourd'hui comme une bonne idée
évidemment c'est un ordinateur qui
choisit les noms et les numéros de
téléphone pour eux ils sont devant un
écran ne choisissent pas ils y sont pour
rien c'est important de le dire parce
que le mal leur parler ou les envoyer
balader ça ne changera rien à la limite
se peut même se retourner contre vous
parce qu'il peut vous remettre dans le
fichier des clients a appelé qui n'ont
pas été appelés juste pour le plaisir de
dire qu'un autre collègue qui va vous
rappeler demain et un autre après demain
et un autre après après demain et ça ça
m'amène à ma première astuce ma première
astuce et qu'il ne faut pas leur dire
que vous n'avez pas le temps maintenant
ou que vous êtes pressé même de leur
demander de rappeler plus tard
eux ils n'attendent qu'une seule chose
quand vous dites je n'ai pas le temps ça
veut dire je n'ai pas le temps pour le
moment mais je veux bien être des
marchés c'est une manière pour eux de
vous remettre dans le fichier clients
des clients a rappelé plus tard vous
allez pas vous débarrasser d'eux comme
ça parce que c'est pas un nicolas
derrière son standard que son fichier de
clients appelé je vous le rappelle c'est
un ordinateur c'est un fichier
informatique donc si vous dites à la
personne qui vous appelle je n'ai pas le
temps de dire ok y'a pas de problème on
peut vous rappeler qu'en à je ne sais
pas fin de semaine un truc comme ça il
vous remet dans le fichier clients le
fichier des gens a rappelé et vous
inquiétez pas
et rappelez ya pas de problème avec ça
ce qui m'amène à la deuxième astuces qui
est aussi simple la deuxième astuces et
ne leur vrai crochet par année ne leur
parlez pas violemment pour l'heure
raccroché au nez ça marche pas non plus
ça vous remet dans le fichier cliente
avait deviné la troisième astuce c'est
de ne jamais s'intéresser à ce qu'ils
viennent vous apporter ce qui viennent
vous vendre parce qu'en réalité même si
c'est pas clairement énoncé comme ça ils
ont toujours quelque chose à vendre
évidemment n'appelle pas pour prendre de
vos nouvelles très rare ça va quand même
nous montrer jamais un signe comme quoi
vous êtes intéressés donc ne leur posait
pas de question ne montraient pas d'
intérêts ne discutait pas avec eux c'est
pas votre copain c'est pas votre pote il
faut pas discuter ça ça rien du tout il
faut surtout clore ce débat et faire en
sorte qu'on ne vous rappelle pas
d'ailleurs n'essayez jamais d'argumenter
avec eux pour leur prouver qu'ils ont
tort sur le produit et pourquoi faut pas
alimentés avec eux je vais vous le dire
parce que derrière cette procédure
téléphonique
il ya quelqu'un comme moi qui a pris le
temps de leur faire un petit arbre des
possibles quelqu'un qui anticipent vos
réponses à l'avant ce qui va anticiper
un argumentaire donc vous n'aurez pas
d'arguments valables auxquels ils
n'auront pas de réponse quoi qu'il
arrive ils auront une réponse ils ont un
arbre comme ça des possibles et suivre
le cheminement c'est pas eux qui
appelait chaussée en temps réel ils
lisent juste un document pour ça on
argumente quatrième as tu si on veut
vous vendre un produit classique comme
de la téléphonie une assurance une box
internet ce genre de produit là il ya un
argument ultime qui est imparable qui va
clore la conversation tout de suite
parce que ça ils n'ont plus rien après
c'est de dire que c'est votre employeur
qui vous le pays bas c'est un mensonge
ça va bien oui mais c'est un bon en
songe pour pu être rappelées ci on vous
propose de changer d'opérateur
téléphonique par exemple dit mais non
mais ça c'est pas moi qui m'en occupe
c'est mon employeur qui me fait ça parce
que j'ai un très bon employeur qui me
paie tout que je m'occupe de rien
pourront pas vous faire changer
d'opérateur puisque vous n'êtes plus le
décideur appartement ou n'est plus le
décideur vous n'êtes pas la bonne
personne à appeler et vous disparaissez
du fichier est mais parfois cette astuce
là ne fonctionne pas et c'est pour ça
que j'appelle ici aujourd'hui et
maintenant l'astuce numéro 5
par exemple quelqu'un qui appelle en
disant bonjour c'est edf je vous appelle
pour faire un point sur votre ligne va
pas se mentir tu vas avoir du mal à leur
faire croire que c'est un employeur qui
payent la facture d'électricité pas
déconner non plus il a de fortes chances
que ce soit pas edf qui soit au bout du
fil
si j'utilise toujours la même astuce je
leur demande mon identifiant vous allez
sentir un léger bug de l'autre côté et
vous dites clairement écouter tant que
vous n'êtes pas capable de donner mon
numéro de client chez vous je ne
répondrai pas à vos questions merci de
ne plus me rappeler donc je vous ne
l'avez pas c'était magique s'est testé
et s'est prouvé par bibi on ne vous
rappelle plus la dernière astuce
elle est censée fonctionner dans 100%
des cas parce qu'elle se base aussi sur
la loi malheureusement elles ne
fonctionnent pas à chaque fois mais ça
vaut le coup de le faire parce que ça va
éliminer des coups de fil à répétition à
la toute fin de la conversation au
moment où ils prennent congé et vous
assez rapidement donc cic l'instant
parce qu'une fois qu'ils ont compris
qu'avec vous il pouvait plus rien faire
ils se dépêchent à vous dire aurevoir
demandé d'être sur la liste des
personnes à ne plus rappelé pas être
effacée du fichier si vous faites est
passé du fichier vous pouvez il ya créé
inscrit un autre jour donc vous demander
à être inscrits dans le fichier des
personnes qui ne doivent plus être
contactés que c'était donc les six
astuces pour ne plus être embêté par le
démarchage téléphonique ce sont mes
vrais astuces et celle que j'utilise
vraiment vous m'avez posé cette question
il ya une heure sur instagram
je recommencerai ça sur d'autres
mercredi et je vous annonce un nouvel
objectif mon objectif il est à 2500
abonnés c'est un objectif que je place
ici aujourd'hui je le plat cela le place
ici là tout autour de moi et dès qu'on
serait à 2500 abonnés je montrais une
diffusion soit sur périscope soit sur
youtube
je sais pas encore en live avec vous on
pourra discuter en direct ce faire des
trucs de mentalist en fait on se prendra
une heure tous ensemble un espèce
d'apéro géant mais où chacun amène sa
boisson et lâche et puis on se met ça à
2500 abonnés donc je compte sur vous si
vous n'êtes pas abonnés à la page
cliquez sur le bouton abonne toi si vous
êtes un blog ou un journal et que vous
comptez reprendre mes astuces vous le
pouvez mais mettais ma vidéo est citée
moi ça me fait plaisir sinon après ben
je suis très très triste et c'est déjà
arrivé deux fois ci cette vidéo vous a
plu partagera partout sur internet ça
peut servir à plein d'autres personnes
que vous et on se retrouve demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao